ich habe das präsidium und der vorstand
der partei darüber informiert dass ich
mit dem heutigen tage vom abend das
vorsitzenden erst heute zurücktrete
aber ich will ihnen das sagen was ich
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen gesagt
habe ich scheide ohne bitterkeit und
ohne groll aus diesem abend ich habe es
knapp ein jahr versehen
ich habe in diesen höhen und tiefen
erlebt wie man sie in der politik in
dieser form selten erlebt das ist schon
so und das bleibt hat man auch nicht in
den klamotten hängen
manches geht auch unter die haut aber
unsere vorfahren wussten schon genau was
sie und zweiter gegeben haben dann
volksweisheiten zeit heilt wunden und
natürlich bekommen an wunden mit aber
die zeit wird sie heilen und die
sozialdemokratische partei deutschlands
da bin ich ganz sicher mit andrea nagel
ist an ihrer spitze
und ich hoffe mit der zustimmung ihrer
mitglieder in der bundesregierung zu
alter kraft zurückfinden wenn ich mit
meinem amtsverzicht ein stück dazu
beitragen kann
dann hat er sich gelohnt